وزيره خارجيه سلوفينيا
السيده الثانيه اهلا وسهلا بك شكرا على
حضورك معنا كيف تنظرون الى هذه الحرب الى
هذه هذه الاشتباكات في السودان
نعم
احييكم بدايه من حيث خذنا محادثات حول
السودان
تحت مظله وزاره الخارجيه الاوروبيه نحن
دين
الاشتباكات الدائره التي تهدد حياه
المئات من المدنيين وهناك قلق بخصوص الامن
والاستقرار في البلد في هذا السياقه نحن
نريد استخدام كل قوتنا على المستوى الدولي
من اجل ان يتوقف العنف من اجل اخلاص
البنادق في السودان وحمايه حياه الناس
وفتح ممرات امنه ايضا
ايضا جزع من اجل اخلاء واخراج المدنيين من
مناطق النزاع لكن القلق مازال مستمرا ونرى
بان النزاع وصل الى ابعاد
اقليميه لذلك نحن ندعو كل الاطراف
ان تتراجع عن اي من مستويات التصعيد
النساء تقولين انه وصل الى ابعاد اقليميه
ما المقصود ماذا تقصدين بذلك
هناك قلق بخصوص النزاع المستمر
وهناك مخاطر
لانتشار
النزاع واتساع رقعه النزاع وقد لا يكون
بوسع الفرقه في السودان بمفردهم ان يوقفوا
هذا النزاع علينا كلنا ان نقوم بكل شيء من
اجل ان يتوقف العنف من اجل حمايه المدنيه
من اجل اسكات
المدافع وهنا كل
اللاعبين الدولي لديهم دور يلعبوه في هذا
الاطار ايضا ينبغي ان نذكر
بجهود السودانيين من نساء وشباب كانوا
يتظاهرون قبل اربع سنوات من اجل
مستقبل السودان لذلك ادعو
الجميع اللي يلعب دورا من اجل ان يتم
ايصال المعونات الانسانيه والطبيه بالنسبه
للضحايا وبالنسبه للمدنيين وهنا ينبغي ان
يكون مجمع الدولي المتحده في عمله
طبعا هنالك اجتماع اجتماع لوكسمبورج وزراء
الخارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا الموضوع
قيد النقاش لكن ما الذي يمكن ان يفعله
الاتحاد الاوروبي الان ما هي الخطوات التي
يمكن ان تكون محل اتفاق الجميع ويمكن ان
تساعد السودانيين في وقف هذه الاشتباكات
هناك طبعا نقاش مطول حول الوضع في السودان
نقاش ما بين
الشركاء الاوروبيين
وهناك ضروره
لحمايه المدنيين واخلاء المدنيين هناك
ضروره لتنسيق بشكل افضل من اجل وقف النزاع
في السودان من اجل وقف الحرب وينبغي دعم
المدنيين النساء الشباب ايضا من اجل تلافي
اتساع لرقعه هذه الحرب لكن ما هي الادوات
التي في ايديكم دول اوروبيه واتحاد
الاوروبي لتحقيق ذلك
نعم بدايه
وقبل كل شيء حمايه
المدنيين هذا شيء هام جدا لذلك
لدينا الكثير من
الموظفين على الارض يقدمون الدعم
وقمنا كما رايتم باخلاء واجلاء الكثير من
المدنيين في المرحله الراينه
[موسيقى]
ونحن هنا بصدد تقديم الدعم للجميع وندعو
لوقف اطلاق النار وايضا القيام باخلاء
واجلاء المدنيين وحمايه الناس ما هي
الاولويه بالنسبه لكم الان وقف اطلاق
النار ام اجلال الرعايه الاوروبيين من
السودان
طبعا الاثنان في نفس المقام وفي نفس مرتبه
الاولويه واقفه اطلاق النار مهم وحمايه
المدني المهمه ايضا وقفه اطلاق النار
يساهم في الحفاظ على حياه الناس لذلك نحن
بحاجه
لزياده جهد المجتمع الدولي من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار وبنفس المقام حمايه حياه
الناس على الارض ومساعده اولئك الذين هم
بحاجه لمغادره السودان
يعني كان هنالك تلويح امريكي بعقوبات عبر
سفير الامريكيه في مجلس الامن بعقوبات على
من يعرق الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
الان وقد اشتبك المكون العسكري مع بعضه
البعض هل تفكرون ايضا في عقوبات على من
يعرقل الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان وضع
قائمه بالاسماء
بالجهات وهل يمكن اعتبار جهه من جهه
الصراع الحالي معوقه للانتقال الديمقراطي
اجتماع ما زال قائما ومن المبكر نتحدث عن
عقوبات الى غايه الان لم نتحدث حول هذا
الموضوع نقاش كان نقاشا عاما حول ما يمكن
القيام به من اجل مساعده
السودان وكيف بالامكان في وقفه تلقى النار
وحمايه حياه الناس والمدنيين اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا تعني وزيره خارجيه سلوفينيا كانت
معنا